je travaille actuellement chez moi je
fais 800 martinets par jour sur une
machine faite par Monsieur André moi je
fais que l'ordinaire réservant à ma
patronne Suzanne les martinets pour les
sex-shop
là je fais les lanières c'est pour la
fabrication de martinet là nous faisons
le Martine et ordinaire avec celle-là
sur une machine qui a été inventée et
faite complètement par Monsieur André
c'est les parents qui élève mal leurs
enfants
parce que de mon temps mon père ne
criait pas il nous donne un coup de
casquette c'est dans les pas ou un une
claque souvent une claque et à l'école
avec couture derrière puis c'était bon
et on se plaignait pas parce que si on
était prêté à l'école ce serait plein à
la maison on aurait pu encore autant
je trouve qu'on était on savait dire
bonjour ça veut dire merci Gregos
aujourd'hui vous savez quand on leur dit
bonjour c'est non c'est non je trouve
que c'est les parents qui les mâles les
enfants
voilà si vous en avez tant pis pour vous
et merci une machine que j'ai fabriquée
moi-même pour tronçonner mes pièces pour
ma fabrication des machines que je fais
tube corner à faire plat enfin tout ce
qu'il faut toutes les machines qui sont
chez nous c'est lui qui les a faites non
inventés aussi
dans l'état d'ordures même
arrêté tout ça non non
non parce que c'est les machines que qui
existent ailleurs mais beaucoup plus
perfectionné
c'est tout à fait simple mécanique mais
c'est simple et ça nous fait un bon
moment quand même et maintenant quel âge
avez-vous l'un et l'autre
moi j'ai 77 et vous 78 et vous continuez
à travailler avec les machines vous
travaillez ici avec vos mains combien
d'heures
ça peut être 8h ça peut être 10 heures
ça peut être 4 heures ça dépend tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours
dimanche
je le vois pas
je travaille actuellement chez moi je
fais 800 martinets par jour sur une
machine faite par Monsieur André moi je
fais que l'ordinaire réservant à ma
patronne Suzanne les martinets pour les
sections on a fait environ 250 250 000
par an
mais les classiques
oui parce que j'ai encore pas fait des
j'ai fait des modèles là je me lance
dans pour faire des modèles mais j'en ai
encore pas devant je suis pas rentré
encore dans un sex shop et je dirais
sûrement pas je voudrais bien savoir les
prix ça fait 44 ans qu'on est tous les
deux dans le métier on n'a jamais plus
de vacances et on est heureux comme le
poisson dans l'eau nos vacances cette
tripoter notre cuir c'est d'être chez
nous on est tranquille on est heureux un
poisson dans l'eau moi c'est un poisson
dans la ferraille
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on ferait
quand même oui mais en fait tu es quand
même mieux latérale que le cuir
ça va me dire
c'est pas ma fabrication
les journalistes sont venus et il me
taquinent avec le martinet de sex shop
et au bout d'un moment je mets au fait
pourquoi je ferai pas je fais des
martinets on me demande un modèle je
vais faire n'importe quel modèle j'ai
les manches j'ai le cuir alors pour moi
je peux faire n'importe quel modèle mais
je voudrais bien savoir si c'est
vraiment pour donner du plaisir ou si
c'est pour faire mal
voudrais savoir je sais pas je demande à
savoir
à mon âge j'ai passé
on peut faire les Martinez qu'on fait
maintenant ça va
on verra jamais on nous invitera pas
je me verrais mal abonnés
mais vous pouvez importer justement là
pour dire on aimerait agistrer une
séance et vous allez recevoir peut-être
des invitations grâce à la télévision
qui va s'adresser à vous
aussi ça paye assez maintenant on verra
vous voulez être payé pour assister
bien charnues qu'on peut au moins avoir
si le martinet s'enroule bien autour
non non pas du tout
et vous feriez ça avec un garçon oh non
seulement
j'ai horreur des films porno ça
m'intéresse pas du tout
moi je voudrais que on interdit ça à la
télévision
mais
vous le regardez pas
comme il regarde de temps en temps je
relève le nez pour voir mais je me mets
en colère à chaque fois
ah ça c'est bien
des innocents
pour mettre des petites boules dorées
sur des entourages afin d'agrémenter le
matin
c'est joli c'est beau
il est très sages c'est plus efficace ça
fait plus mal que
j'ai pas essayé
j'ai pas essayé je sais pas du tout
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous André
Martinez
mais vous devriez essayer tout ça parce
que vous fabriquez les choses en savoir
c'est pas mon métier de donner la PC non
plus moi
de voiture ils essayent de voiture avant
de se lancer dans une série quand il
essaye c'est pas l'utiliser
pour le faire des pilotes
c'est pas moi l'essayer
il faut savoir qui sont des choses
vraiment efficaces
moi je sais pas je pense qu'ils sont
efficaces c'est tout
comment poser la question
de la pénitencier
des choses incroyables alors faut croire
que les gens sont sincères
j'ai l'impression que ça vient beaucoup
de l'étranger quand même
le français ne font pas
les Français il ferait pas ça oh les
Français sont pas mieux que les autres
vous savez mais je trouve que ces
articles là ça vient certainement des
pays nordiques ou des pays je sais pas
ce compte scandinave ou je sais pas moi
si vous voulez on fera la copie